[Musique]
l'albatros qui parmi vous se souvient de
l'albatros de baudelaire
rappelez-vous souvent pour s'amuser
les hommes d'équipage prennent des
albatros vaste oiseaux des mères qui
suivent
indolents compagnon de voyage le navire
glissant sur les gouffres amers
à peine les antilles le déposer sur les
planches que ces rois de l'azur
maladroit et on te laisse heureusement
leurs grandes ailes blanches comme des
avirons treiner et côté d'eux ce
voyageur et les comme il est gauche et
veulent vie naguère si beau qu'il est
comique et les lins agace son bec avec
un brûlot gueule l'autre mime en boitant
la firme qui volait le poète est
semblable au prince des nuées qui hante
la tempête et se rit de l'arche et exilé
sur le sol au milieu des huées ses ailes
de géant l'empêchent de marcher ce poème
que mon grand-père mfi y découvrir et
apprécier ce n'est que récemment que
j'ai réalisé à quel point il était
prémonitoire
mais pour que vous puissiez comprendre
pourquoi
permettez moi de commencer par un petit
flashback
je vous emmène avec moi en février 2004
à l'époque c'est bright 'future' je vole
comme un albatros à la conquête du monde
asie moyen-orient etats-unis
j'enchaîne les jobs à responsabilité en
prime une vie de famille épanouie et une
femme super de petite fille adorables le
bonheur total
mais ça c'était avant
avant
en cette nuit du 5 mars 2004 où rentré
la veille du japon je me réveille vers
de 3 heures du matin je veux me lever
mais je ne sens plus mes jambes je perd
alors le contrôle de ma vie
hospitalisation examens médicaux et ont
fini par me dire monsieur c'est une
sclérose en plaques et un médecin me
lâche la vie normale le sport vous
oubliez la sclérose en plaques
c'est une maladie du système nerveux
central qui impacte le cerveau la moelle
épinière et peut créer différents types
de handicap des troubles visible troupe
de l' équilibre de la marche la vue et
puis aussi moins connus du handicap
invisible des douleurs la concentration
les problèmes de mémoire et le reste je
ne m'en souviens plus le diagnostic est
tombé comme un couperet
commence alors une longue et
vertigineuse chute
imaginez j'étais sur nos routes de
montagne et j'allais vers mes objectifs
et bien cette route cette route s est
écroulé et je tombe avec je tombe
inexorablement l'impression que ça ne va
jamais s'arrêter
et là on me dit et je me dis no future
je suis ko ko en bas d'immenses falaise
j'essaye de remonter mais j'ai
l'impression de vivre le mythe de
sisyphe
je tire je pousse ma maladie et au fur à
mesure de ces évolutions
je retombe
- violemment avec des choses pas simple
à vivre comme la première fois que je me
suis retrouvé dans un fauteuil roulant
pendant une douzaine d'années j'essaye
de remonter la pente professionnelle en
cachant ma maladie au maximum surtout
que ça ne se voit pas je bidouille en
permanence que les gens ne se rendent
pas compte
et puis la maladie s'accélère deuxième
chaos
exit le monde professionnel à 47 ans
direction la retraite ou pas j'avais
commencé quelques années avant à
pratiquer le viniyoga qui m'a appris à
être centré ne pas trop me projeter en
parallèle c'est la chance d'avoir un
support familial exceptionnel et je peux
le dire aujourd'hui
je ne vous remercierai jamais assez pour
toute l'aide que vous m'avez apportés
pour vous j'ai envie de me battre de ne
rien lâcher et j'ai décidé que plutôt
que de continuer à ramer contre la
sclérose en plaques
j'allais essayer de pagayer avec elle
est là cette maladie omniprésente
eh bien on va avancer ensemble à visage
découvert
créer un nouveau chemin et partir pour
une aventure que j'ai appelé l' aventure
et steve c'est un mot que j'ai inventé
achu pour humaine et st ive pour
sportive et donc le 14 août 2017
je suis parti
de paris pour rallier marseille en kayak
en solitaire pour vous donner une idée
de la dimension sportive que ça
représente
c'est un peu plus de 1000 km 55 jours de
pagayage soit en moyenne un semi
marathon par jour à la force de mes deux
moteurs écologiques bras gauche bras
droit et puis je garantis pas le chiffre
à la virgule près mais un demi million
de coups de pagaie c'est beaucoup tout
ça mais c'est pas le plus important le
plus important est né dans la dimension
humaine de cette aventure car je voulais
à l'air aller à la rencontre des malades
et leur dire on sait que c'est compliqué
une maladie dégénérative mais ne lâchez
rien fait comme nous le dit
saint-exupéry fait de ta vie un rêve et
d'un rêve une réalité
ça permet de mettre en place des projets
et puis d'aller à la rencontre des
autres et des rencontres pendant ce
périple
j'en ai fait plein tout plus grandioses
les unes que les autres
quand je naviguais et que des gens
passer à côté je leur faisais c'est
encore loin marseille
vous imaginez et me voyez sur mon petit
kayak comme ça rigolait j'ai eu droit
toutes les réponses prochaine à gauche
quant à plus de carburant tu es dans le
mauvais sens
c'était surtout un bon moyen de rentrer
en contact et d'échanger avec les
personnes
je me suis
aussi ça devait être mi septembre un
malade qui me dit je te suis depuis le
14 août et grâce à toi j'ai repris le
sport et bat son témoignage il
m'apportait jusqu'à marseille
car ce n'est pas seuls que j'ai réussi
ce défi
c'est grâce à beaucoup dead un exemple
c'est pour dormir soit j'avais chez des
amis qui me sortait de l'eau ça me
permettait d'avoir une bonne soirée une
bonne nuit
soit j'ai dormi dans des campings quand
c'était à 100-200 mètres de l'eau et que
je pouvais gérer
j'ai aussi dormi chez des gens que je ne
connaissais pas c'était fabuleux
ils m'ont accueilli comme si j'étais un
ami de toujours
et puis il ya eu aussi beaucoup de
bivouac et là c'était parfois un peu
plus rock'n'roll
je me souviens dans le sud de la france
je trouve un endroit sympa pour poser la
tente genre les affaires du kayak et
puis je fais le tour du bivouac voiture
que tout est ok je passe derrière un
bosquet et là en face de moi un troupeau
de taureaux camarguais
imaginez je suis en gilet rouge maillot
de bain rouge en face de moi un gros
taureau je suis sans mauvais jeu de mots
sclérosé foudroyé je le regarde il me
regarde on se regarde et là je sais pas
ce qui m'a pris j'ai pris mes jambes à
mon cou
enfin vous aimez gêner ce que ça donne
avec ma démarche
et puis d'étape en étape je me suis
rapproché de mon rêve souvent sur le
parcours les gens me disaient tu arrives
quant à marseille je répondais le 7
octobre ce qui était déjà ambitieux
plusieurs semaines à l'avance de donner
une date précise mais je me disais mais
quand le 7 octobre
alors pour tourner la question en
dérision m'amuser un peu et marqué les
esprits j'ai répondu 10h02 et bien
mesdames et messieurs à 10h02 le 7
octobre je rentrais dans le port de
marseille
[Applaudissements]
alors une telle aventure ne s'improvise
pas si je suis arrivé au bout de ce rêve
c'est grâce à une grosse préparation
pendant un an technique kayak bien sûr
mais aussi beaucoup de rééducation dont
six semaines en clinique spécialisée
avant de partir et puis toute la
logistique le parcours les autorisations
et j'en passe utiliser des techniques de
visualisation et mentalisation d'image
m'a aussi beaucoup aidé est ce que vous
connaissez le pont canal de briare c'est
une construction du 19e siècle il
fascine et bien j'avais imaginé
visualisez mentaliser sur mon kayak à
l'entrée du pont canal pour passer au
dessus de la loire victorieux pour
célébrer des dix premiers jours
davanture ce qui m'a aussi aidé ce sont
les rituels ne pas penser à marseille se
concentrer sur l'étape du jour et chaque
soir célébrer l'arrivée comme une petite
victoire et peut dans 55 jours organisé
les journées du matin au soir
de la même façon pour être centré 1
voyage initiatique il m'a appris
beaucoup de choses sur moi il m'a permis
de passer de l'albatros maladroit zeeuw
tel que le décrit baudelaire à
l'albatros qui vole au dessus des flots
et qui marche tel qu'il est avant je ne
serais jamais venu sur scène avec une
chaise je me serais montré en superman
jaurès serrer les dents je serais resté
debout quittâmes effondré juste après
dans les coulisses c'est aussi cela
pagayer avec la maladie
c'est s'adapter c'est accepter de vivre
avec ça la maladie telle qu'on est
devant le regard des autres comme devant
vous aujourd'hui c'est accepter l'aide
que l'on m'apporte et j'en ai eu plein
tellement que cela m'a rassuré sur le
genre humain
cela m'a redonné confiance
cela m'a même donné envie de penser à
une nouvelle aventure qui pourrait
l'emmener vers les contrées lointaines
dont parle si bien l'aventurier qui m'a
fais de me rapprocher des banquises qui
comme moi sont en pleine dégénérescence
mais plus seul cette fois de partager
avec d'autres
ces moments d'exception et c'est pour ça
qu actuellement nous travaillons sur une
nouvelle aventure aventure eu steve 2
qui va nous emmener quatre personnes qui
ont une sclérose en plaques et 4 valide
pour démontrer que tous ensemble on dit
plus valides
on peut aller au bout du monde alors on
sera pas exactement au bout du monde
mais pas très loin à 1000 km du pôle
nord était 2019
nous allons naviguer dans l'arctique au
delà du cercle polaire sur la côte-nord
du spitzberg tout là haut c'est pratique
la can de temps en temps tout là-haut et
là on va essayer de passer le 80e
parallèle nord en kayak
là haut il n'y a rien rien ni personne à
part les ours blancs qui nous obligeront
à faire des tours de garde pendant les
bivouacs là haut nous ne pourront
compter que sur notre complémentarité
pour aller au bout de notre rêve car
c'est cela que l'on veut aussi vivre et
partager tous ensemble on est plus fort
on va plus loin l'entr'aide ça permet de
réaliser des rêves incroyable de
redonner de l'espoir
finalement quand on a des gros soucis
on peut ne rien faire mais ne rien faire
c'est reculer
on peut aussi lutter contre je le sais
je le fais pendant beaucoup trop
longtemps ça mène nulle part
c'est no future c'est vrai c'est parfois
dur très dur de s'adapter de bouger mais
réaliser ses rêves
ça permet d'avancer de partage et de
vivre cela
a va peut-être en choquer certains mais
grâce à la maladie vous savez c'est lui
c'est l'histoire du verre à moitié plein
je dis bien grâce à la maladie je me
suis inventé un nouveau futur
impensable alors oui c'est possible
tel un albatros de s'envoler vers de
nouveaux horizons à la rencontre de nos
rêves
mais n'attendez pas qu'il soit trop tard
le futur c'est maintenant qu'il faut le
vivre sénat au futur merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]